animal crossing New Horizons is a game
that's meant to be played over many
weeks so if you're like us you're still
playing and discovering new things every
day that means we have a couple more
tips to make you the best resident
representative around faster crafting
this one may seem a bit obvious but you
can significantly speed up crafting time
and animal crossing new horizons by
spamming the a button during the
crafting animation this is especially
useful when you are mass producing the
hot item of the day or fish beat
infrastructure tips chances are by the
time you've unlocked the residents
services building you'll want to move a
few buildings and build a couple bridges
and slopes the catch is that you can
only relocate one building per day and
you can only have one public works
project open at a time
this makes development feel a tad slow
especially if you plan on redesigning
your entire Island however it's
important to keep in mind that Tom Nook
can take on a relocation project and a
bridge or slope project at the same time
pitfall seeds
apart from earning you some nook miles
pitfall seeds don't serve much of a
material purpose in Animal Crossing new
horizons but I'd be lying if I said they
weren't fun the best way to get pitfall
seeds is through a DIY recipe however if
you have a friend who's already found
the recipe they can bury the seed in the
ground for you when you dig it up you'll
automatically learn the recipe welcoming
new villagers you're probably aware that
you can send letters to villagers at the
airport but you might be surprised at
what kinds of words and ideas they will
recognize for example you can send a
welcome letter to a new villager and
they'll respond thanking you for making
them feel at home on their new Island
this boosts your friendship with them
balloon spawns there are a few things
you should know about how balloons work
especially if you're hoping to get DIY
recipes or other specific items from
them first the color of the balloon
doesn't determine what's in the present
it's random second they'll spawn from
the east during the day and the west at
night catching pests if you're trying to
complete your critter pedia there's a
few semi hidden bugs you need to know
about flies ants and fleas you can catch
flies and ants at any time of the year
and during any time of day to catch
flies set up some garbage you fished up
and walk around until a fly starts
buzzing around them
to catch ants do the same with spoiled
turnips fleas will appear on poor
unsuspecting villagers from April to
November in the Northern Hemisphere and
from October to May in the southern
hemisphere they'll talk about being
itchy so to catch the flea and also do
them a favor just swing your net at them
you won't actually hit them with your
net and they'll be grateful instead of
peeved okay that's all the time I've got
I got to get back to playing Animal
Crossing new horizons on my Nintendo
switch if there are any more tips you
found please let us know in the comments
below and be sure to check out our other
Animal Crossing guides like 11 things
you should do every day and how to
become a millionaire thanks for watching
[Music]